Kylie Jenner's cleavage at sparks the  new speculation is she got a boob job  the 19 year old that shared these  snapchats on Thursday keeping the camera  focused on her chest which was on full  display in a row healing army green top  followers started to ask if Kylie had  gone under the knife recently I have had  food poisoning over the weekend and it  has not been fun so that's why I've been  a little ma or if my snapshots aren't as  fun and exciting yes Kylie was quick to  clap back to the boob job talk saying  her chest is a hundred percent hers it's  just that time of the month of course  Kylie has shut down these at same rumors  before showing off her push-up bra  tricks on her app I just use the  bombshell by Victoria's Secret it's  life-changing  I've gotten all my sisters on it all my  friends